[Music]
ah London had a good run there for a
while now it's alright
bombings and people thrown in cages like
animals
oh I know you can forget the killer
robots everywhere
so yeah that's not gonna [ __ ] it's up
to us to take our city back thing is if
we can't do it alone we need to recruit
a resistance I know what you're thinking
where do we start open your eyes and
take a look around look here look it in
now not in him
former mi5 duty never ends it can get
anywhere and erase anyone see her London
she got kicked out of Oxford for a
bottle school for teaching him to
reproduce
[Music]
and I fell over their proper Berlin come
on drama me ill crack your skull just
for looking at funny
[Music]
this had better be good
and allow me to introduce you to the
deadliest of the love this is not out
she's experienced
like I said you can recruit anyone and
all me bloody anyone him/her everyone is
a secret weapon
find them recruit them
build the resistance
let's on this world
you